this weekend I was watching and
performance
I made the trek to Hawaii to hang with
my guy Kevin Hart now had in hula girls
and his keb mo G's and all I can say is
paradise will never be the same
Kev's in Hawaii promoting his new
concert movie what now shot in his
hometown of Philly that's gonna make
these people that it was one of the
greatest nights in your life wasn't it
it was man it's by far I can honestly
say the biggest moment in my career to
think or imagine that would one day saw
the football stadium yeah and it's not
that I'm not listening to you but there
are two women who love dancing behind so
I get a little oh okay all right
we know where his face is on millions of
phones
Kevin's camogie app is a best-seller it
gives fans a Kevin approved emotion for
all of their texting needs I want to get
the cab moji for that dance they were
doing just a minute ago can I get some
mochi for that again mochi for that
right here yeah okay
Brandon Angelina break up before you go
I want to ask you your emoji for another
great interview on et with me
Wow I'm migite the face want break down
I'm breaking down I can camp de camões
you where I broke down you know why cuz
I got a good relationship with this guy
I did this for you I thought you did
this is all about you the dancer I
appreciate the dancer thank the cab one
time just one time time for cab thank
you know what I'm not looking good why
cuz I got my wife